foreign
foreign
my
hello everyone and thanks for making
time for this webinar
today i will talk about agilent
solutions for metabolomic studies with a
focus on data analysis and visualization
tools
and hopefully this will be useful for
your current or future experiments
so let's get started so agilent has a
long history of working with multiple
metabolomics community dating back to
the first
metabolomic society meeting in 2004.
since then we developed tools bought
hardware and software to facilitate
metabolomics research so let's look at
our comprehensive metabolomics portfolio
which includes sample preparation
separation techniques
mass spectrum mass spectrometry
consumables
and application software and for
separation we offer
lc systems gc systems sfc systems and ce
systems
and for mass spec site we have single
quads triple quads and
time of light systems including iron
mobility
and we have a full range of consumables
that would support
all these three areas however getting
the data in metabolomics research as
many of you would agree is just the
beginning and
many times most of the time tip of the
iceberg so we need specialized
software to mine our data and
and most of the time find the needle in
the haystack
here we see our software portfolio
and at the center we have our mass
center core software
comprised by acquisition software
qualitative analysis
and also the quantitative analysis and
link to this core software we have
profinder for future extraction mass
profiler professional for chem metrics
analysis and visualization
we have agilent metal and fiend
libraries for identification and
annotation
and we have a recent tool lipid
annotator for epidomics workflow
workflows and annotation of lipids
we are part of the architect for
biological interpretation of
our data we have a molecular structure
correlator
to interpret our msms results especially
useful when we don't have any hit in the
databases or
libraries whether commercial or in-house
and then we have our vistaflux
software and workflow for stabilizer
isotope tracing experiments
such as fluxonics
and broadly if you look at approaches in
metabolomics
we have discovery or untargeted analysis
approach and we have the targeted
approach in the discovery approach we
collect data
on all metabolites or as many of them as
we can
and then typically we do relative
quantitation
and and and most of the time uh high
resolution accurate messy instruments
such as our top systems are used for
this purpose
and for targeted analysis we acquire
data on
only a target list that we are
interested whether they are from a
particular pathway that we are
interested
or maybe they are from literature
related to some particular disease
and we can do relative and absolute
quantitation in this case
because we will be using uh triple quads
most of the time
and having absolute quantitation might
be very useful
because we can have comparisons to
normal ranges
of metabolites in biological systems
and let's look at some of our recent
additions to our metabolomics portfolio
so here we see in the six steps of a
typical metabolomics
analysis starting from sample prep in
acquisition
finding our features identifying or
annotating them
then we have our statistical analysis
and finally
we do biological interpretation most of
the time
so let's start with sample preparation
last year we introduced our
bravo metabolomics platform which can be
really useful
for plasma sample preparation and
improves
precision accuracy and throughput
greatly
and it comes with optimized protocols
for on-site and off-site
plasma collection and off-site
protocol can be very useful if we have a
collaborator
not located in the same building can be
another place or even another country
which is becoming more often
these days with large-scale studies and
it also uses captiva emr
emr stands for enhanced matrix removal
epic system to remove proteins and
lipids and let's look at it in a bit
more detail
so the proteins and lipids in our
matrix can cause signal suppression and
also it can
they can cause a variation in the signal
in our chromatography systems
so this is why we would ideally want to
remove them
and this is exactly what a captiva emr
lipid removal system does besides lipids
it also removes protein precipitate
which
we form usually after quenching our
sample
and how it does is it uses the long
hydrophobic
chains in the lipid structures and
entraps them in its
sorbent leaving the small molecules for
analysis
and it comes with either cartridge
format or
a 96 well plate format and here we are
seeing
the effect of using captio emr tool and
removing the lipids so so here we if you
don't
remove them you see the intensity level
here and when we use them
due to the less signal suppression
the signal enhance greatly as you see
and just note that
the y-axis is same for both cases
but what if we want to uh analyze lipids
if
what if we want to do lipidomics
experiment so in this case we don't want
to remove the lipids but we want to
extract and isolate them
and to do exactly this we just launched
earlier this year this year
a system called one elute lipid
extraction
and it it selectively retains the lipids
in the sorbent and after a washing step
we can elevate those lipids for our
analysis
and again this can be a great tool for
hydro put sample prep and automation
and it again comes in cartridge format
or
96 well plate format and here's a link
to learn more about
this new and exciting product
so the second step in our metabolomics
workflow is
acquiring our data and last year we
launched our
6546lc cutoff system which is really an
ideal instrument for metabolomics
analysis
with this new 10ghz electronics it can
simultaneously acquire high resolution
and wide dynamic range data
and again this is something we all want
for metabolomics
studies so we we are not only interested
in high abundance molecules
or metabolize but also low abundance
ones and having them
together in in the same spectrum
is very important and it has an
increased mass resolution greater than
30k for low mass
and and greater than 60k for high mass
range
and it supports high speed
chromatography
in other words resolution stays
independent of acquisition speed and and
this is very important again when we
really acquire data in
high speed in msms experiments this can
be very
useful and
one acquisition mode that we also
recently introduced is iterative msms
modes
and it's available uh acquisition
revision 10
upwards and and the main feature for
this mode is it maximizes data
dependent msms or in agilent's
terminology or instruments we know it
has auto msms
acquired so and how it does is that
it performs multiple injections on the
same sample
as you see here and it excludes the
precursors that were already
fragmented and analyzed in the previous
injections
so then we'll have a authoring exclusion
list and
and by doing that we would have a better
coverage especially
uh to include low abundance compounds
and also just note that having an
isolation experiment such as this
is uh adventure advantages in in many
respects
compared to a data independent
acquisition where we fragment everything
and then would be difficult to correlate
fragments to the precursor line
and on the acquisition side of things we
also introduced
recently a helic
column as we named it poroshell z column
as you might know many of the
metabolites
or many of those that are very
interesting biologically
can be polar especially in central
carbon metabolism or tca cycle
and glycolysis pathways etc and reverse
phase
columns may not be very good at
retaining them and and these polar
metabolites might elude
early on in the chromatography and
traditionally helix separation suffered
from unstable retention times
and also varying peak widths
but with this helic column we have a
novel
civility ionic stationary phase that
provides a robust chromatography
and also we also introduce a deactivator
additive solution which
improves detection and peak shape for
many metal sensitive metabolites such as
those
having phosphoryl groups and here we are
seeing an example of this
on the left here under positive ion mode
at ph3 we have a separation of amino
acids under 15 minutes
and note the separation of leucine and
isoleucine
they are separated at the baseline
on the right if you look at the negative
eye mode separation at ph 9 we are
seeing a number of metabolites including
many that were phosphorylated and
and prone to having distorted peak
shapes thanks to the helix c column and
the additive
as you see we have very sharp peaks even
even for
for them such as atp and nadh with
phosphoryl groups
and also we have a tool for targeted
metabolomics
as we call it metabolomics
dynamic amaram database and method so
using this
we can measure 219 central carbon
metabolites
and it provides an optimized lc triple
quad method
for stable and robust chromatography and
and using this method we wouldn't
well spend so much time or minimize time
for method development
and optimization and here we are seeing
an example of
this separation using an ion pair
reverse phase
separation and and this can be really a
useful
tool if you want to study those polar
central carbon metabolites
and if you want to analyze volatile
compounds
we have our 7250 gc cutoff system
and we also introduced the chemical
ionization options for that
and using this system we we obtain
accurate mass for both ms and msms
modes and we will obtain a high
resolution
more than 25k at a low mass
range and with a mass accuracy of less
than 2 ppm
and using the low energy ei mode we can
produce msms spectra and which would
help for
identification of unknowns especially
those that are not present in the
libraries
right so as we move to the third step
which is
a feature finding and one of the crucial
steps
in the metabolomics workflow our
solution for that is masshunter
profinder
and we released version 10 recently
and using this tool we can quickly
perform batch analysis of our
ms data files and extract features
quickly across
batches of samples and we can visualize
and also
edit the results by metabolite which is
really a unique feature of
profinder so let's look at it in a bit
more detail
it can analyze up to 200 lcqt of data
files
if we have more than that we can do
batches and then we can
perform batch normalization in mpp stage
and this is a single um tool for
untargeted and targeted feature
extraction
and it has the ability to do fast and
multi-threaded batch processing
utilizing
our advanced computers and laptops these
days
and it has an optional chromato warping
as you see here
in the middle diagram so this is
especially useful
if you have retention time shifts that
are not linear
so this warping you can imagine it as
kind of a
compressing or elongating an elastic
band and
and using this algorithm we can fix some
of those retention time
shifts and it also performs a recursive
batch analysis to minimize false
positive
and as a result missing values which can
be a headache for our statistics
many times we will look at that in a bit
more detail
and we also have compound-centric review
rather than an iron centric view and and
with
with this we would have much fewer uh
list of uh
items that are going to statistics and
by combining isotope peaks and other
peaks
we would have a better understanding of
our data even at the future extraction
stage
but let's look at the interface of
profinder we have four main panes we
have the compound groups pane where we
select a particular
compound and then we have the compound
details view
where we see details for the selected
compound
based on the samples that we are
that we acquired and in the middle we
have the
chromatogram results pane we can have
over lady ics here and we can color them
based on samples
we can overlay all of them to check on
the consistency of
integration and on the right we have
the sample spectra and
one export option also we introduced
recently and which is very useful
is profinder archive format
so if we use this format it will export
just one file instead of multiple
shelf files which was the case earlier
or compound exchange file format
and also the profinder archive export
would retain
the grouping information of our sample
then we don't need to
enter that information again in mass
profiler professional stage
and we also we also have the option to
export to csv format if you
if you like to analyze maybe the data in
excel or any other
open source tool and one
other option i would like to emphasize
emphasizes we have an
option to deal with missing values
either we can export them as
true zero values if you are really
confident there is no
the intensity is zero there after maybe
we go through our
results but we also have the option to
export them as
missing in other words not putting any
value in that particular cell
so this missing flag can be very useful
and
and we can do some flexible operations
in mpp stage
and finally on profinder if you look at
the
algorithms we have four extraction
algorithm
the first one is batch molecular feature
extraction which is a naive algorithm
which is and it is untargeted in other
words
but the advantage is it's very fast and
it reduces false positive
based on the analysis of isotopic and
rock peaks and we can use it to optimize
our parameters before
performing our recursive feature
extraction
and in this recursive feature extraction
we have a two-stage
process and
we first we perform mlv mfe algorithm as
we as we just saw
and later on using the results from mfe
we use that
target list to perform fine by
ion in a in a way a targeted extraction
and any well some of the features that
were not depicted by mfe would be
picked by find by iron and as a result
we would reduce false
negatives and missing values and we have
a batch targeted feature extraction
option
again this is useful if you are
interested only a panel of metabolites
rather than extracting
everything and we also have a batch
isotopolog extraction algorithm which is
used for
again as i mentioned earlier iso
stabilization of tracing experiments and
fluxonic studies
and this is also part of our vista flux
workflow
and if you are dealing with gcms data
besides
uh having the option of profinder we
also have a
tool known as unknown analysis
which is part of our quantitative
analysis package
and using this tool uh we can do batch
feature extraction on our gcms data we
have an option of
uh sure mess and the convolution
algorithms
again we can visualize and edit results
by metapolite
and we have the ability to search
multiple libraries which can be
very useful and talking of libraries
that
bring us to our fourth step in our
metabolomics
workflow and
what is very important here is
that knowing that this is the bottleneck
of metabolomic studies
these days we need
reliable and high quality databases
and our solution for lcms data is that
is sorry
is agilent matlin database and library
which comes out of
gary's use deck lab at the scripps
institute in u.s
but we extensively create uh this
database for high accuracy and quality
and it also includes many msms spectred
multiple
collision energies and if you look at
the diagram here we are seeing them at
10 20 and 40 electron volt
and having multiple collision energies
gives us extra
confidence about our identification or
annotation
and for gcms data we have agilent fiend
metabolomics library which
was developed by dr oliver finn
at uc davis and it provides a gc ms
retention time lock method
and also ai library with retention time
index
and another exciting tool that we
introduce
for identification step or
maybe for lipids case annotation step
is lipid annotator tool and it's the in
silico lipid annotation tool
and we can also create a personal
component database library after that
and it uses a unique search algorithm
to together with a theoretical lipid
library
and it annotates msms spectra from both
lc qtof and also
ion mobility kyoto systems that we
provide
and we also have targeted and untargeted
workflows using lipid annotator so
let's look at um some of the lipids and
epidomics terminology and lipid
annotator in a little bit more detail
so the lipids was an analytical
challenge
from an identification perspective
because
the number of lipid standards
commercially available is around only
1100
however number of lipids in the
biological systems are
hundreds of thousands if not millions if
you consider the exact stereochemistry
and to deal with this uh problem
majority of lipid msms are annotated
using
in silicon sms libraries broadly
speaking using
only accurate mess data we can annotate
based on class and com
and elemental composition over a
deeper annotation uh required to get a
class spec
to get annotation on class specific
fragments
and also for our group ions
and these green items that use that are
listed here
the class information elemental
composition number of double bonds
our group size and location are
typically
can be obtained from mass spectrometry
analysis
the double bond location is a little bit
tricky and depends on the fragmentation
pattern of the lipid
and for double bond geometry uh whether
they're cis or trans we need
most of the time specialized techniques
such as
ozonolysis and here we see an example of
lipid
which is a phospholipid to just
understand the complexity so we have
three r groups as you see
and one of them determines the clause of
the lipids which we call head group
and by changing the r group there we can
have phosphatidylcholine
class of lipids or phosphatidyl glycerol
lipids
and by changes in the other two r groups
we can have isomers based on chain
length
based on degree of unsaturation based on
position of the double bond in the fatty
acid chain
and also based on orientation of the
double bond whether it is or trans
and and this is just one class of lipids
and i think
knowing that we have many classes of
lipids but technically there are eight
classes of lipids and there are many
subclasses
of them we can see the complexity of
lipid
annotation and identification
so to deal with this complexity it is
very useful to have a separation before
the mass spec analysis stage
and and choosing the platform for this
separation impacts the class of lipids
resolved
and detected if we look at the table
here while gcms may be good for certain
lipid classes
in general lc and sfc systems are
broadly applicable
for repeat analysis and normal phase lc
separation usually provides separation
based on lipid classes sfc systems
provide a better resolution
on this lipid class separation
and reverse phase separation which is
the dominant
technique for lipid analysis
can well separates based on
hydrophobicity depending on the r
group and also the double bonds and many
times it can also separate
the isomers and let's have a look at one
example of that
so here we see cis and trans isomers of
phosphatidyl glycerol and
and based on just slight difference in
hydrophobicity due to the
uh double bond we can separate cis
isomer from
trans-isomer but if we didn't have this
chromatography and if you just perform
the shotgun or infused method approach
we would have lost this information
and cis entrance well isomoscana
completed completely different
biological
impact in a pathway so it is it is very
important to
to annotate them as best as we can
and if you look at our lipid annotator
tool in a little bit more detail
it's based on lipid blast theoretical
library roughly half a million entries
and we also added 14 lipid standards to
it
so that we can perform class-based
normalization during our statistical
analysis
and it annotates an msms spectra from
either automatic sms modes or iterative
msms mode
or from ion mobility alliance mods
and eventually after performing
annotation we can export the results
to an accurate mass retention time
database
and or or we can also export to a csv
format
and then we can use this database to
mine our
ms1 profiling data so if you look at the
the diagram here uh just visually it
might be easier to to explain the
workflow initially we
typically perform iterative msms
experiments on a pool
qc sample to represent
our study samples and to the better
coverage maybe five or six
injections and after lipid annotation
um we export the result and
in this database later on can be used in
an untargeted workflow
or in a targeted workflow for a targeted
workflow we use
profinder in a targeted feature
extraction mode and and point
pointed to this database so that we only
extract the features based on
this database or we can perform
an untargeted approach using an answer
using an untargeted feature algorithm
feature extraction algorithm and later
on at mpp stage
we can use this database that we
obtained from the
annotator to annotate our results and
with that we would have bought annotated
and
announced the unannotated results in our
mpp
and there are a few ways to further
annotate them which we will look at it
in a while and
here we see how territorial msms can
help us dig
deep in in our data with with each
subsequent injection
and again this is very important for
metabolomic studies to have a good
coverage
of metabolites
and and on the right here we see how
iterative msms compares to a traditional
data dependent uh acquisition
and we see that the number of lipids
annotated
are greatly higher when we use the
iterative approach
as a result that we are basically
acquiring and annotating
more of the lipids
if we look at the interface of lipid
annotator tool here
in on the top left we have the feature
plot view
where we can visualize the features with
colors based on their lipid classes
and also we have options to change the
x's here
we have a mass retention time plot but
we can have others as well
and we also have a pie chart on the
right side
to easily visualize the number of
lipid classes that are present in our
sample and we have the feature table
here at the bottom that includes both
annotated and unannotated
lipid features and if we go to the match
details view
in this case we only have those annotate
annotated lipids listed in our lipid sum
composition table
and we have a lipid composite lipid
constituents table here
which lists the possible constituents
based on
the matching to the database
fragmentation spectra
and based on goodness of the
non-negatively squares fit they are
given
they are given abundance percentage and
assume that area a little bit and if
this abundance percentage is more than a
certain threshold than other candidates
then this particular constituent
candidate is reported as a dominant
constituent in our table
so in this case here we are seeing 16 0
and 22
4 reported as a dominant constituent on
top of having
the sum composition annotation
but if you don't have this kind of
confidence among the lipid constituent
candidates
such as maybe in this particular case we
have three of them but
we cannot distinguish among them based
on the goodness of the
fit to the database fragmentation
spectra
in this case we don't report any
dominant constituent annotation and we
just leave it at
leave it at some composition level so
without
giving details about the side chain so
as you see this is
very important not to over annotate
lipids which is
which can be a problem and which is kind
of a problem in the literature
so we so in this tool we try to annotate
based on
the information that we have so
and not more so this is very important
to minimize
false positives and and you know
inaccurate
annotations
and the other step the fifth step in our
workflow is statistical analysis and
visualization
and our tool for that is mass profiler
professional of which we released
version 15 recently and one of the main
features of this version is having the
ability to automate
statistical analysis and i'm sure this
can be very
useful and good news for
many people who don't really want to be
bogged down in statistical analysis
and maybe someone who is more
experienced in his statistical
techniques can
provide a method and then this method
can be shared
with others and can be used at
the click of a button and also we can
incorporate some r scripting if you wish
to and if you are
proficient about it into this automation
steps
and let's have a look at some of the
features of mass profiler professional
it is really a central tool in our
chemometrics workflows and
it accepts lcms data whether
triple quad or cutoff and it accepts
gcms data again whether it's
quadrupolar or tough data and we can
also have icpms data for metallomic
studies for example and
we can have a generic file import for
nmr data
or for other render data a1
and we can perform many types of
statistical analysis i will
just go through some of them in in
subsequent slides
and we have a id browser module within
immense profiler professional
for us to perform identification based
on
the databases that we have and we have a
hardware architect module which is
optional for biological
interpretation and on the left we see
some some
graphics a volcano plot here combining t
test and fall change
and we have principal component analysis
here an unsupervised
multivariate tool and also we have a
mass retention time plot and as you
see mpp can produce very
high quality graphs and we can export
them for our
publications if we look at the interface
of
mass profiler professional we have on
the left projects and under projects we
have experiments
for example a positive mode experiment
can be one experiment and negative mode
can be another and in the middle we have
the plot area
as well three of which i have shown you
just now
and on the right we have many workflows
and
operations grouped under categories to
make
analysis easy especially for beginners
again mpp really has lots of features
and
and tests and we don't have time to go
through all of them in this
presentation but let me go through
some of them at least by name and let's
have a bird's-eye view of them
so we have many data normalization
options which can be
very useful depending on what type of
sample we have for example for urine
samples which can be very important
to offset for concentration
differences and we have many
visualization options we have
quality control options i will i will
have us one slide on that later on
and we have many statistical analysis
tools whether it's
univariate in statistical tests such as
t-test
and oa or whether there are multivariate
tests
and for unsupervised category we have
pca and clustering
and for a supervised month variations or
class prediction
category we have again a number of tools
including plsta
which is quite commonly used and others
and for biological interpretation we
have
pathway architect and other tools and
they also have included with recent
versions options for
scripting for example are or or python
if you are proficient with that and and
this scripting
can really expand the capabilities of
mpp
you know greatly
so let's look at just some of the
features again since we don't have time
to go through all of them
so the quality control is very important
in metabolomic studies and
needs to be performed virtually on all
metabolomics analysis
and in mpp we can perform that either on
samples or on metabolites so for samples
we can visualize a pca plot and
if you see we can see trends and
grouping information
and if you see some outliers at this
stage we can investigate
and if you have a justified reason to
remove that we have an option
to remove that and then remodel the pca
based on
the new sample set and for metabolized
filtering we have many options based on
their frequency in the samples
based on their variable sample
variability
based on whether they follow a normal
distribution or not
and whether they have a flag and
remember the missing flag we talk in pro
finder
we can have many operations using that
flag here
and we can filter also based on
abundance and
let me just mention at this stage
filtering on sample
variability can be useful and can be
used together with
pooled qc samples and and typically
if you have a variation more than 20 or
25 percent
even in qc samples which are basically
injecting from the same while then
normally we would like to exclude those
features from further analysis so that
we save our time and also we don't want
to spend
you know time on annotation or
identification for such
features that are not as good quality
and as for the univariate tests we have
a range of
tests whether it's student thetas
or anova or whether and they're
parametric and non-parametric versions
and a range of multiple testing
correction techniques
and also we have a fault change option
uh which we can combine with these tests
for example for t tests as we saw
earlier uh
we can have a volcano plot when combined
with a whole change
well this number of tests can be
overwhelming
even for maybe seasoned
statisticians so but the good thing is
mpp
suggests tests based on the data and the
grouping that we have
so that can be a very good place to have
an initial analysis
and start our analysis for further
optimization
and for multivariate tools and class
prediction tools
we have a number of them and with the
most recent version we have included
three new algorithms named random forest
linear discriminant analysis and simcoe
and also with the most recent version
version we have
a vip squares plot well uh
and also we have a discriminant power
plot and and they can be used
for shortlisting potential biomarkers
and and using for example this vip which
stands for variable importance in
projection plot
we can select say top 10 or 20 again
this depends on the study
uh metabolize that contribute much to
the separation in plsda
to be our potential biomarkers and then
we can investigate them
further so it is very useful for a
differential feature selection and we
have a clustering analysis option as
well and which we can perform based on
the conditions as you see here or based
on
the metabolites and based on the trends
certain areas we may want to
investigate further using pathway
analysis and see if this variation is a
result of some
disturbances in one particular pathway
and we have correlation analysis to
uncover relations between metabolites
and this is one of the main purposes of
metabolomics anyway to see how
metabolites
relate to each other and whether they
increase or decrease
together and if you zoom in this area a
little bit the moment we click on any
particular cell
then this pop-up will appear showing us
the correlation details based on well
between these two
uh metabolites and we can know our
correlation coefficient and
and coefficient of determination and and
also the equation
and we can have an idea about the nature
of
relationship between those two
metabolites
and we can also easily determine unique
metabolites specific to our
groups and and one way uh to do this
is perf generating when diagrams as you
see on the
left or we can or if you want to have
more details
and for different permutations of our
groups we can have a table
format as well
and the final feature i want to talk on
mass profiler professional
is our new lipidomics workflow
so we have included a new lipidomics a
new experiment type which is lipidomics
when we are generating our
experiment and when we choose that
downstream
we will have our non-class-based lipid
normalization
actuated and we can choose those
lipids that i mentioned placed in the
lipid annotator database
those internal standards and and which
we would also
need to put in our samples and we can
select them in
lipid class normalization would be
performed based on them
and the other useful tool is kendrick
mass defect plot which can be useful in
epidemic studies
so basically ch2 groups being
the most common repeating unit in in
lipids we set its mass to an exact
14.0 value and any deviations from this
would contribute to the
kendrick mass defect so so based on that
addition of ch2 groups would not change
the mass defect and we would have a
horizontal
pattern but having more double bonds
would have a pattern pointing
in this case you know northwest and if
we add carbon
and double bonds together then we would
have a pattern
pointing northeast and if we briefly
look at this example here
we have a trend of threshold glycerols
ten
double bonds nine and eight and we would
expect this unannotated feature
um to be based on the strength of 58.7
and indeed if you calculate the mass of
this differential glycerols
it's only 3.63 ppm different from our
accurate mass that we
measured in our analysis so this can be
a great tool for further annotation
on top of lipid annotation annotations
and and the final step is the pathway
analysis and our solution for that is
a pathway architect and and in using
this we can map our differential
metabolites to
pathway data databases such as cac
biocycle or wiki pathways
and we can perform multi-omics
experiments as you see here we can have
we can make proteins
from our proteomics experiment for
example onto the same pathway
together with our metabolites and and
by doing that we can generate hypotheses
and guide our future experiments
and here we see the interface of that
here we have the list of pathways that
have at least one match
of our metabolites and the pathway view
are the metabolites that are mature
indicated over there and their data
values are indicated in a
heat map format down there
and one unique feature of pathway
architect is ability to use numbers
instead of
names to map our database names to
to pathway names so this can be very
useful
and as because as you know compounds
metabolize they have
many names common names ipac names etc
and having this kind of
database identify numbers instead of
those names would provide us
that accuracy for mapping them onto
pathways
and and finally pathway architect can
provide us
visual tools to identify shared or
unique pathways
across our experiment as you see in this
example
and the final part of my presentation i
would like to highlight some results
from
one of our recent application nodes
which is
about a drug treatment in the leukemia
cancer cells
so basically what we wanted to do was
compare our agilent
lipid profiling workflow to a published
shotgun study
and the citation of which you see at the
bottom
and in this study basically we had three
treatment groups
and namely a drug named mpa and another
drug name be z
and another group which is a combination
of
the the two drugs that is labeled
bap and we have our vehicle control as
well
and we had four replicas from each so
after
24 hour incubation and extraction of
lipids
we analyze our iterative msms data from
the pooled samples
and the result was we got a 30 430
lipids
representing 17 classes in positive ion
mode
and 650 trillions from 25 classes
representing
the negative ion mode and without any
further filtering when we perform
our pca analysis we see that and this is
in agreement with the published
study that the combination treatment
placed furthest from the vehicle control
group in both pcas
which shows its efficacy and also if you
look at
the horizontal component which shows the
most variation
in the data principle component one we
see that
treatment be that in both cases
contribute more
than mpa treatment to the combine effect
of bap and if you look at some of the
results
from that analysis if we look at the
lipid matrix
view in mpp in agreement with the paper
we see an increase
in in triangle glycerols from vehicle to
control
and it decreases in diastoles as we move
from vehicle control
vip treatment and what was different
from the paper was that we didn't
observe a significant
change in in in lies of
phosphatidylcholines or
lysophosphatidyl ethanol amines
and what was not measured in the paper
but what was measured in our study was
that a decrease
in phosphatidylcholine levels as you
move from control to ebip
treatment and also an increase in nine
hydroxyceramide levels
and an example to show the importance of
profiling approach in other words having
that
separation before mass spec we can look
at
this lipid uh matrix that just focus
focused on the nine hundred
9-hydroxyceramide
and we have a number of isomers that are
marked with asterisks there
and if you focus on one of them we see
that they had opposite trends
between vehicle and bap group and here
we are seeing their
uh overlaid eic's from profinder
and we see that lipid annotator
annotated their constituent levels based
on the difference
in in fragmentation pattern one had an
eighteen one twenty four one pattern and
the other eighteen twenty one four
zero and we see that the difference
between
these two uh fragments was s2
uh two six three and 261
representing one double bond or in other
words two hydrogen atoms and same goes
for
here three nine zero and three nine two
and and finally i would like to go back
to our untargeted lipidomics workflow
where we can annotate previously and
unannotated results
so here we change the horizontal axis in
our kendrick master effect plot
to a lipid class which can be done very
easily in mpp
and then we see that each lipid class
has their particular range for candid
mass defect
and this particular feature was not
annotated but it was highly differential
in statistical analysis
and that's why we wanted to annotate it
and we see there are three
uh lipid classes that that fall in the
range of this
mass defect uh as this an
unannotated feature and if we look at
the
zoom level and try uh
nine hydroxyceramide
[Music]
combinations and this can be done easily
with lipid calculator tool in lipid
annotator
we have found easily
this lipid structure which differs only
by 0.3 ppm
from our measured accurate bass and and
this can be a great way to to further
annotate structures
in our untargeted workflow
and with that i want to leave you with
our application notes that i have
mentioned during the slides and also
you can follow our linkedin page or our
omics webinar page on our agilent.com
website for
further updates and information on
comic studies with that thanks for your
time and you can have any questions